hi
welcome to cargo
spooky okay all right
attention to all personnel proceed to
evacuate
an s-class object has escaped from
containment
move to the nearest sector stay in until
an all clear announcement is made by the
cargo special operations
thank you for your time this some kind
of sap deal
hello oh hi i'm red
you are not red how are you doing i mean
i'm not red
wait oh i'm an idiot hi hello how are
you
is this c for me uh you shouldn't have
hey
you're the new one right don't worry
this kind of [ __ ] happens all the time
that's something that shouldn't happen
all the time probably escapes of
high containment object things like scp
but this is different because it's cargo
that should probably not happen anyways
i see it taken all right
see you handsome interesting hello you
have nothing to say
all right this is uh can i shoot nope
all right cool hey how are you doing
buddy hey good to see you
well i was looking at your beautiful
face but i guess i'm not gonna do that
anymore okay you guys are lovely are you
guys coming with me or do i go down
there by myself
and uh die okay cool thanks
hey really appreciate it sending me down
on my lonesome
this is great oh hello
hi sorry to run at you
man if someone came down the stairs and
ran full sprint straight at me after
walking i'd be
pissing my pants gear lexie run at me as
fast as you can
yeah it's pretty scary pretty scary
thank you proving my point
hey go left there's a there's yellow
there oh thank you
there's a lot to clean down there oh one
of my janitor
my janitor with a gun i have a combo gun
mop
by clean do you mean i need to kill
someone
or something oh i'm red again no i'm not
i'm alone i just realized it why am i
alone there was like four people up
there and yet i'm sat down here alone
hi oh there's people down here did you
kill that man
did you kill that man did you softly
suspicious
you have to admit strange he has a class
c infection but it wasn't that that
killed them
do classy infections usually cause all
of your blood to explode out of your
body
cause that's not cool you know i had
heard from a friend of mine that there's
another company like ours
what friend what would your friend know
that you wouldn't know
in this company some problems you know
containment leaks scientists dying
he also told me that they had once
caught some kind of giant peanut thing
crazy sure man okay good stuff hey
we got problem down here apparently hey
bud have you seen
uh something killing people all right
all right all right all right all right
okay
all right rookie do you see that black
thing in the bottom there we have to get
rid of all of them
oh the thing oh okay that's um
that's a problem just get close to them
and press rmb to aim and they'll
be to fire don't touch them because they
infect you and that's not covered by
insurance
oh great
[Music]
sorry sorry to do that right by your
ears buddy
how's your eyes they good oh that's
birthday oh they're dead
they were already dead i didn't kill
them maybe you did
oh i'm sorry that's not funny
this is a very serious job we got
we got to take care of this stuff okay
who brought a toilet down here
who brought a reaper from mass effect
down here
you bring your is that a plant did you
die next to a plant
i guess it's nice i don't know i
shouldn't question it you're dead and i
should have
bigger concerns than what you died next
to
oh this looks promising oh
i don't like the hanging ball sacks
that's something i don't know
i see undulations around the corner
man i am really good at my job i
am stunning well i sure am glad that i'm
the only all right
hey okay good job over there how did you
know that
go down and continue cleaning why why am
i alone i'm the new guy
you're sending the new guy down there
this is new guy training
oh yeah this is a job for the new guy
this guy's new
send him down first
well oh fun thanks glad i can't move and
shoot
[Music]
hello hello
oh god how did i miss you gross
oh no no i'm amazing ignore that
miss there please edit that out lick
soon make it seem
flawless
thank you what is happening
what is happening wait a minute what's
happening
oh i don't like whether
that is normal oh yeah it's normal
oh yeah it's it's normal elixion can you
uh actually play that
play that audio in reverse
speed it up slow down
double it and now decode it and
translate it in the bottom
okay thank you for that everybody knows
oh big head hi how are you doing big
head how are you doing
big ed ah that's all i have to say about
you big head i do not like that
that was un comfy hi oh hi sorry
i got a call hang on shut up stop dying
for a second i gotta
take this one good room full of dead
people
none of them soldiers i guess so i got a
good shot at oh my god
how did you get there oh my god how i
thought that was his legs for a second
look at his legs had been in that wall
that would have been great
too all right
oh yeah you're fine i mean you're dead
but yeah you did you didn't die hor
well maybe you died i forget i said
anything
all units we need back up in sector nine
ready to repeat we need backup
are you wait are you down below me are
there more people down here
was i not the first one sent in it
really seems like i might have been the
first one
oh good great hello hi
hey oh i can't okay well it's oddly
normal down here
i mean besides oh
oh that's not good whatever that is
oh no oh no not yellow
oh
oh my god yeah i'm not going to stick
around for that
oh no please not the ballsacks
[Music]
please oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh we're right into it okay we're going
now are we
oh i don't need to shoot that one oh my
god
okay hug the uh hug the corners
oh come on oh jeez oh geez scuba
geez where is he oh god holy gods
cat suits oh god
all right okay we're going right away
we're going now
here's when we're going i skipped that
one oh wait i can oh
ah okay
i can't be caught shooting all of them
no way that's for losers
me i'm an economical with my bullets
oh no come on oh god hey how you doing
come on come on come on go go go is
there any more i can't see i'm blind
what no i was blind okay where is it
where is i can't see i can't see i can't
see i can't see okay i'm good i'm good
i'm good i'm good
well i mean push a button maybe
okay you good man you good you're good
okay you good
you're not good are you oh you are good
oh
oh i actually made it out
that never happens i like that a lot
that was very good
i enjoyed that a great deal there was a
lot going on there it wasn't a very like
refined game
it didn't look perfect it was very
polygonal but for what they were doing
it was very good i liked them a lot
thank you
moving on let's go
go study i'm playing go study this is go
study the games go study
finally back home i received this
package today
let's see
let's see what stay home well i mean
good advice oh package right
hello how are you doing look at that
smile nothing of beauty
okay open package
i severed head oh no oh god
dear students thank you for
participating the aim of this case
studies develop a rich understanding of
the physical and psychological effects
of infrasonic frequencies we've prepared
an audio playback device and cd with
sounds containing the mentioned
different sonic frequencies furthermore
we have to inform you that earlier
studies have shown that this could cause
a minor side effect including but not
limited to panic attacks feelings of
fear motor ataxia
anxiety nausea visual disturbance and
degraded task performance some
participants also reported the odd
sensations that they would then
attribute to the paranormal
encounters this is why we also call
these frequencies the ghost frequencies
if you are experiencing any of the
mentioned effects please remain calm and
stop the audio playback immediately you
may also end the experiment at any point
we have prepared a feedback form
in which we will ask you to report your
experience good great so if you feel any
of these symptoms
any at all
okay cool disc man put cd in
disc band do i have it in my hand there
it goes
sure close disc man play disc man
what a strange sound
listen closely i'm trying man
crank it oh my god bad time to crank it
i should close the window yeah jesus
christ
look see why did you crank it like that
good god okay close the window
well that's much better that's a good
window i can listen to myself think
look at this picture of my hopefully
girlfriend hey
how you doing keep your teeth clean oh
good advice i guess
am i supposed to be doing anything
is this an attempt to commune what was
the objective of this study hello
did i say something go by my window
did i say something oh oh
oh oh oh okay sure yeah
i'll play your game you rogue or never
mind
i was going to go outside apparently i'm
not going to do that
you know i can turn on more lights than
this lexian
i hesitate to ask but oh
wait hold that there's a note pick up no
good thing i didn't ask you to crank it
that was going to be loud
i'll be with you in a moment the tandy
was that it v tandy hey what's up mom
dad nobody
turned back on oh that didn't even know
that turned off i was wondering about
the light situation
remember i was wondering you guys
remember i was i was wondering about
that
i didn't know this opened i'll go inside
i can't close it from within
okay i guess that's it then okay that's
enough i'm gonna turn this thing off
here i go
well that's taken care of now and
forever i feel so dizzy well that's a
little weird i should lie down and rest
for a moment
hell picture why not no problem with
that
what is happening what am i looking at
what is going on who's you
i'm in my closet hello
well particularly remember going in
there
oh oh oh
i guess we're fine it doesn't stop i
can't even pull out the cable
what is happening all right i should
have a hammer around here somewhere
should i should i have that oh i should
get ready to crank it
not the best thing to crank but what how
it's still playing
if i smash the speaker oh god
noose on the tree really there you lie
oh you don't lie you not lie
hi
silly [ __ ] you think that that's going
to scare me
you have no evidence that i was afraid
of that
idiot lexie and delete all the evidence
what are you doing what are you what are
you what are you doing to me
what is happening to me right now you
slapping my ass
did you come in here to slap my ass you
my ass uh
wait what oh no
oh no
no sarah
sarah is she
she is i i didn't
i thought it was what
what have i done
that's my girlfriend from that picture
one of one of six one of
six six take sir yeah i'll take the
survey
all right here we go wow that's an
actual survey holy [ __ ] thank you very
participating how long were you exposed
hey about
ten minutes what physical phases did you
experience
uh uh spook what
psychological ex spook did you
experience anything that could be
described as a paranormal encounter yes
you believe in ghosts no were you alone
maybe were you really alone maybe
well that was cool but sit one of six
all right you know i'm not gonna go find
him
but you guys can go find him maybe
there's a secret ending to find
links are in the description you should
go check it out but that was good
i like that thanks workers moving on
[Music]
oh
you have been selected to participate in
an experiment
conducted by labs
the focus of this experiment is to study
human behavior
under stressful conditions your
objective
is to enter a maze locate and press five
buttons
and return to the room you currently
occupy
buttons will emit a quiet beeping to
alert you
when you are in sufficient proximity
we advise you to use the glow sticks we
have provided
to assist you in returning after all
buttons
are pressed there are a number of
non-human
entities within the maze whose objective
it is to prevent you from completing
yours
such entities will have three states
represented by
lights located on their abdomen
a passive state is represented by
a green color in this state the entities
will be barred
from any interaction with you a
searching state
is represented by an orange color
in this state the entities will be
attempting to discover
your location when faced with an
entity in this state researchers
recommend
turning your flashlight to its lowest
setting and hiding
red lights represent an active state
the entities will have no restrictions
in this state
do not remain in proximity to an entity
in this state you will have a remote
which will restrict the movement of all
entities
upon pressing the button labeled with a
queue
this button will fail to function after
three activations
if you return from the maze you will be
psychometrically
analyzed and rewarded with a 500
check you will be forced to sign an
nda if this document is breached in
any capacity you will be returned to our
facilities
pull the lever adjacent to the
loudspeaker to enter the maze
this is all the information we may
provide you at this time
there's a lot of information to
participate it's a lot of information
thank you
labs i really appreciate your candor in
this trying time
that i've put myself in for a 500 gift
card hey that's a good deal but you
probably should have had me sign that
nda before
you sent me into the death cave uh just
saying
okay so i go in and i oh with the big
door i'm not tall enough to get this
all right that didn't work out for me
something green
orange red green means not going
orange means orange you around here
red means re
okay oh
that's much less efficient than just a
door
oh god okay drop that there
sure let's go for it oh
okay i don't know how big this place is
so
i don't exactly know how conservative i
need to be with these
glow sticks oh i love mazes
i love mazes
oh my god oh my god
it's almost like there's entities in
here and they're probably non-human
i don't see any light i just hear thunk
alongs what is this
ventilation to what a wall [ __ ]
these i'm i'm putting these glow sticks
in the absolute worst places possible
what what what what what what what what
what
what what
oh you're helping me
that's strange okay oh
why why press f why why f
oh what
okay ah you know i really should have
put these in kind of a trail
oh how did i do that
i don't know i don't know oh how did i
have closings there but it doesn't make
any sense
wait i'm gonna okay i'm gonna go back to
the one i saw down the way
where did i see it down the way oh god
no
why stop it you [ __ ]
stop it stop it stop that
oh my right oh my god okay i'm back at
the beginning
oh what the
[Music]
what did i do it i thought you said
there were gonna be five
stop buttons that door was not supposed
to open
turn around and return to the testing
area immediately
but do not move any further we will
collect you in the testing waiting area
you are the first candidate to complete
this experiment and we need you to
return
it is imperative that we collect your
psychometric data you are entering
extremely hazardous zone your odds of
survival after entering the zone on year
zero
you have no idea what's in there dr
robinson
start the emergency protocol now
well you know that's wonderful i love
your your
[Music]
i love your megaphone on wheels that's
cool
it only begins i think i must have
broke something or found the secret
something or something or other
what because i was spamming the use
button and what i think happened is
i pressed the same button five times and
somehow that
worked probably a bug but uh yeah i did
it so there's actually another
game in this series
this experiment is bad enough
i guess i can take the time to explain
to you a few things
as your death is croppable within the
next 30 minutes
we never built this facility in fact no
one did it's always
then here we just found it we don't know
too much about it
ourselves actually we think it might be
sentient possibly alien we honestly have
no clue
only things we know for sure really are
the dimensions of this place
that's what the experiments are for we
want to find out what it is
and why it's here but after a couple of
our phds hit the dust exploring we
decided we need alternate candidates
like yourself
if it's any consolation surviving this
experiment will get you back to your
family
we'll do the best we can to help you but
none of us know much about this one
we know from scanning for high density
metal there seems to be about five rooms
always connecting them only one other
test subject
is ever stood in the room you're in
right now ever done this experimenting
if you didn't make it past the first
feel free to make yourself comfortable
while we open the gate
pray to your god better hope he's real
good thanks man thank you
why do you have controls over everything
huh what's going on here
you said i was the first to ever succeed
in the last one and yet there was one
other person here
what do you mean what's going on it's on
me right
why isn't my flashlight adjustable
anymore
okay strange
oh yeah that's normal to be here that's
normal
oh why would hide i don't how do i
hide what do you mean hide
what do you mean hide oh what do you
mean
saw ass [ __ ] i'm hiding oh i can't
what the hell
i'm gonna hide
i'm hiding did i hide good
am i hidden
i don't know what am i hiding from
the wrong spot oh
no oh
no thank you what
the hell wrong with you what's wrong
with you what do i
do what am i supposed to do can they see
me can they hear me do they know what
i'm doing i don't think there is
oh god oh
oh my god uh i'm seemed to be oh
how do i go down i can't go
i'm stuck down stuck i'm stuck i'm stuck
oh stuck can we skip the foreplay can i
thank you good
i shouldn't have gone upstairs if the
thing was just going to be
you know upstairs kind of a bit of a
problem for me
okay there is an uppy but do i need to
go uppy
because then what i need i don't know if
it's what i need
oh the geometry of this place sucks i'm
gonna wait here just to see if there's
something else that'll pop up on the
screen maybe it'll help me
oh no nothing oh it just yeah it just
okay all right you know what oh okay
all right okay all right well it's gonna
have a tough time following me up st
i can't see i couldn't see a thing take
three baby take three gonna get it this
time if i find the
door you i think you said something
about a door if i find the door before
you even
spawn i got this i win
don't i sure wish someone would come out
of the blue and uh
illuminate my path for me in a serene
glowing red oh ask and he shall receive
oh hello
oh so the door only opens after a while
oh
i see how it is i see well i don't even
oh hello oh i may have found it
congratulations oh
what oh
i didn't quite get what you were saying
there ah
nope okay all right here we go
wow none of them worked besides that one
choose one door
i choose this door here i go
good choice they don't know what i say
to you
okay goodbye
right
wait i will save you
sure you will sure
okay all right
hmm look
figure it out
you have five minutes oh good
okay oh that's a lot of codes
um okay
oh okay so
yeah which numbers do they all agree on
the last number
isn't they don't agree on that second to
last number they don't agree on that
fifth number is not agree it's just
guessing
isn't it i don't know but it could only
be one of these
so it's not an infinite possibility okay
all right let's try this last one
wait a minute there's more numbers here
than there is over there
what is that about what is happening
can i help you what i wasn't looking
up there
oh you i hate you well looks like i'm
gonna die
and kaboom
i think even a little bit of toxic gas
would be probably deadly considering
it's toxic
what was this clue that you were going
to give me that was so great and all
that i missed before what was this clue
you went plonky plunk plunk some
something something i should plunkety no
hello i want you to survive
the answer is no
the answer is no so do these transfer
into letters
do i have to look up how to read binary
is that what i have to do
right okay so i'm going to type no in
binary which i didn't
it because it ties into hexadecimal
places which i don't know either
okay zero zero one
one zero one one
one one one one
there hey i did it with my big brain we
hate cowards
proceed
okay cool did i do it right i don't even
care at this point
you gotta look up a binary to
hexadecimal table to get a
get all back and the answer is no
whatever
oh hey how's it go i don't know if the
the
map maker here the maze creators thought
that people just knew
by binary off the top of their head look
there are five generators
turn them on okay oop
wait i'm tired of
seeing you suffer turn on
the generators you will
see
okay this generator a radiator here for
some reason
can i just press one generator five
times i like that in the last one oh
hello i'm not gonna get any boops to
lead me towards it this time
just me wandering around okay
okay what the hell i've been wandering
around
there's one this is going to suck
and if there's something in here that's
going to kill me resetting is going to
suck
so much worse how did they go from
the previous game having the really nice
things clues stuff glow sticks to help
me find where i've been
this one nah nah you're going raw you go
in the r
really oh you are rubbish
oh my god oh my god oh my god is this a
dead oh my god are you kidding me
oh my god there's two of them ah
dodged dodged son of a [ __ ] are they
kidding me
are they yoshing me oh in a circle
already but i didn't find him
oh there's another okay oh god no
okay so there's one more somewhere oh
hi oh great there's one more
oh hello well this sucks
no clue i have no clue i'm a dead end
and no clue
not a clue not a clue where did you
where did you guys come from there was a
way through here
thanks for illuminating the path i guess
whoa hate that what is that all about
what why
stop wait did i see a red light
oh my god oh my god
did i do it
things you couldn't imagine
it's been six months you'll finally see
i'll show you i'll make you see
everything will make sense
all you have to do is wait i promise
okay oh where here huh did i miss it i
blinked i'm sorry
okay so i liked it at first
however the first game had the help it
was bugged obviously i bugged in so i
didn't do it right but
i was terrified the first one the second
time i was just getting frustrated
the puzzles were it's not that they were
hard but it's just like
you don't have the tools to solve them
you know i mean you can't
figure binary out in five minutes
you have to get like a converter or
something an outside helper
you know but being said it had some good
moments that was technically two games
there was obviously a lot more
diverse things happening in the second
one but could do some work on the
spook factor
good
[Music]
you